صحيفه ليموند نشرت تقريرا وجد ان حماس
تواصل القتال رغم العمليات التي يقودها
الجيش الاسرائيلي في قطاع غزه المدمر لم
تتمكن اسرائيل من الوصول الى قاده حماس
ولا تحرير الرهائن وها هي تعرض وقفا
لاطلاق النار قد تتجاوز مدته شهر يقول
التقرير ان مقاتلي حماس اجبروا القوات
الاسرائيليه على الانتشار من جديد في
مناطق ان سحبت منها واعلنت تفكيك فرق حماس
المتحصن فيها وفي هذا تناقض مع الواقع
يضيف
التقرير في الستريت جورنال نقرا ان الحديث
عن تحويل اسرائيل تركيزها بعد خانيونس نحو
رفح يخاطر بالقتال في منطقه مكتظه ويثير
مخاوف تفاقم الازمه الانسانيه في غزه
تتوقف الصحيفه عند تصريحات ل جالنت بشان
الخطوه المستقبليه للجيش ثم تقول انها
تعكس حجم المعضله التي تواجهها الحكومه
الاسرائيليه في تحقيق هدفها المتم مثل في
القضاء على
حماس سلطت صحيفه النيويورك تايمز الضوء
على وثيقه حملت توقيع اكثر من 800 مسؤول
من الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا ودول
اوروبيه للاحتجاج على سياسات اسرائيل تشير
الصحيفه الى ان الموقعين عبروا من خلال
القنوات الداخليه عن معارضتهم لسياسات
حكوماتهم تجاه الحرب في غزه ومخاوفهم من
ان يكون دعم قادتهم لاسرائيل مساهمه في
جرائم الحرب لكن تم
تجاهلهم تناول مقال في صحيفتها ارتس امر
بايدن التنفيذيه المتعلقه بعنف المستوطنين
باعتباره خطوه غير مسبوقه يمكن ان تؤثر
بشكل جذري في المشروع الاستيطاني بالضفه
الغربيه وتضع الاساس لاحتمال فرض عقوبات
على مسؤولين اسرائيليين العقوبات وفق
المقال تبعث برساله قويه لحكومه نتنياهو
بان التسامح مع التوسع الاستيطاني غير
القانوني سيضر بالعلاقات مع الولايات
المتحده نشر موقع ذا هيل نتائج استطلاع
للراي العام الامريكي كشفت عن تاييد نصف
الامريكيين للطرح القائل بان اسرائيل
بالغت في ردها على هجوم حماس النتائج
اظهرت زياده بعشر نقط في نسبه من يعتبرون
ان اسرائيل ذهبت بعيدا في حربها على غزه
مقارنه بما اظهرته نتائج استطلاع اخر اجري
في شهر
نوفمبر